now if you think democrats nuking the
filibuster was just about budget
reconciliation
think again we need to do away with the
filibuster
you know that what's what's what we're
seeing happening in america is
republicans in the senate are more
interested
in eroding voting laws and
increasing gun rights when
you know really should be um the other
way around
oh wait but for the biden white house
that might not be fast enough
we are certainly considering a range of
levers including
working through legislation including
executive actions
executive action to take away your
second amendment rights joining me now
missouri senator josh hawley senator
have the democrats i mean i guess they
have considered the backlash that
they're going to get
for all of this but they don't care
because they are singularly focused on
this gun
issue yeah and they're singularly
focused on control
laura i mean that's what this really
comes down to at the end of the day they
want to have
control over the political process they
don't care about the second amendment
they don't care about the first
amendment and if you disagree with them
they want to write you right out of the
democratic process and
you look at what their gun control all
of their proposals come down to we're
basically heading towards a national gun
registry i mean that's the only way to
make effective
the kind of so-called reforms that they
want it's to register
every firearm in america and you talk
about an infringement on second
amendment rights and what that will lead
to
and we know they also want to confiscate
guns all the democrat presidential
candidates ran on that
just last year so that's what's really
going on here
it's a massive massive power grab and
it's it's downright unconstitutional
well there was a lie that was even for
all their
outrageous falsehoods that they're
peddling
this one was really quite something and
it was amplified
by senator alex padilla in the majority
of states
new voters are able to obtain a rifle
quicker than they're able to cast their
first vote
it seems to me that we have our
priorities entirely backwards when it
comes
to this when we make it easier to buy a
gun
than we do to cast the ballot now
senator
that is not remotely the case but it
gets repeated
and the fact checkers are nowhere to be
found
yeah of course and that's always how it
is laura as we see the
the left-wing establishment media just
amplify whether it's on the second
amendment whether it's their claims on
religious liberty i sat
in the judiciary committee and listened
to the same democrat senators say just
last week on religious liberty
that uh the religious uh freedom
restoration act was something that uh
that no longer is serving the purposes
that it was meant to serve that it
needed to be updated it's all the same
talking points that's what they say now
about the second amendment so again
whether it's your right to worship
your right to bear arms they want to
limit them to take them away
all in service of their political
control and their radical left-wing
agenda what we're seeing is
they are willing to steamroll anything
that stands in their way the rules of
the senate
the will of the voters doesn't matter
they are going to implement their
radical agenda and
nothing is going to stop them the
other thing that keeps getting repeated
is that
oh all you republicans all you can do is
offer thoughts and prayers
and they've kind of had it with the
whole prayer thing
over in the u.s senate when it comes to
the democrats watch
thoughts and prayers are not enough
and yet thoughts and prayers is all we
have heard from my colleagues on
the other side thoughts and prayers must
lead to action is that all you think we
should do
in the wake of these shooting senators
that all the republicans ever want yeah
you know
how about we put violent criminals
behind bars how about instead of
releasing criminals onto the streets how
about instead of looking the other way
as violent crime has soared in this
country which is what the democrats have
done for the last year pretend it isn't
happening
pretending the assaults on police
officers isn't happening pretending that
the murder rate isn't exploding
how about we actually face those facts
and do something about criminals
who get guns criminals who use them in
violent ways that's what we need to be
focused on but they don't want to do
that laura they want to talk about
taking away
firearms from law abiding citizens this
gets us back to their their national
registry which is what they really want
i mean this is about
law abiding citizens second amendment
rights that's what the democrats are
focused on it's exactly the wrong focus
we should be putting people behind bars
who commit violent crimes
but uh you know the democrats they're
more interested
in their own political control and their
radical agenda that's what they're
pursuing and senator really quickly we
understand tonight
according to politico i just mentioned
this in the angle that the dhs
is considering putting uh some of the
people who
they find to be extremist part of the
extremist groups in the united states i
assume
including the capital rioter types on
no-fly lists
and subject them to further surveillance
is it time to ditch the patriot act yeah
i think it really is time to
to ditch the patriot act and have a hard
look at the surveillance state
that congress stood up over 20 years ago
and has been expanded
and expanded and expanded you know laura
this is something that we were told was
was going to be temporary
but we've we have seen now for years how
things like the secret surveillance
court the fisa court has been abused
uh the last administration lied or i
should say the two administrations ago
the obama administration
lied to the fisa court in order to get
wiretaps doj did the same of the trump
campaign
i mean this stuff is out of control it's
being used against their political
opponents it looks like that's what
they're considering senator thank you
great to see you tonight
thank you